you
[Music]
so we have the Public Health Group and
Millington band I'm going to be
presenting on behalf of our group and so
we have some problems that we thought
are ready for immediate collaboration
and I'm going to ask my teammates to
jump in if I misrepresent anything and
so immediate collaboration and then
interesting long-term problems so
immediate collaboration is assignment
and scheduling of health worker visits
with dynamically generated data so as I
understand it the challenge is we have
health workers and they have to plan
routes over you know each person is
assigned maybe a thousand people have to
visit on a large geography they have to
ideally visit each and every home but
that may not work so you may do a risk
based routing so people who have a
higher risk you want to make sure that
they do get visited and so this problem
becomes one of a traveling salesman
problem but interesting because there's
some places have a higher value to be
visited and then that the problem can be
made more and more complicated because
we may want to optimize which health
worker takes on which route the routes
may not be known in advance so they may
be learning of the routes as we go on we
might want to build on existing
relationships and so forth so we created
a four part evaluation of each problem
that we discussed social relevance how
interesting is it from an AI perspective
collaboration opportunity and data
availability of data and this problem
seemed to score high in terms of all of
these dimensions and so this we
considered as our top priority a second
problem was risk-based targeting of
patients for tele advising and
monitoring you can see that there is
some overlap here in the risk-based
approach so basic idea is that this is a
problem where we have to call patients
unfortunately if we call them we can't
we call all the patients all the time
it's very costly to the patients and so
can we target which patients are more
risk prone and therefore those are the
ones you would target a little bit more
and so this is apparently something
where the Gates Foundation has data and
something where we'll be putting we may
have some contacts in order to get that
data this the first problem that I
mentioned this assignment problem it
seems like there's already years of data
available and so that's why this seemed
to be the more interesting problem to
focus on right away so these two are our
problems for immediate collaboration and
then longer-term possibly more
challenging problems was slum health
monitoring here we are trying to locate
diseases within a slum predict some
areas are prone to certain diseases and
therefore recommend actions to stock
medicine awareness can screen for
certain diseases in those areas this is
also a problem of portfolio optimization
because we are trying to figure out
which which medicines to stock up on the
one negative here it seems negative or
is that it seems like this problem has
already received a lot of attention and
so as such it wouldn't be up to us to we
wouldn't be necessarily the first ones
to go into this we may have to
coordinate with lots of other groups but
certainly a very important problem and
something that would be some yield
longer term interesting problem to work
on another one is educating adolescents
on sexual and reproductive health and
this is possibly a peer based approach
so we might take a approach similar to
the work we've done using social
networks to educate people but the
cultural context here may be far more
complex and so it wasn't clear if from
an AI perspective it would be as
interesting but certainly a very
complicated problem
the Genet for health workers based on
decision trees so we want to have these
health workers ask questions to diagnose
diseases however we can't ask lots of
questions so what's the what's the right
set of questions to ask how to develop
so there's a bomb DP style framework
that could be developed to generate
these questions it seemed it seemed that
this could be a problem that's really
important but maybe it doesn't need a
very large-scale collaboration but we
are sort of keeping it in in terms of a
problem that will be in the future
so come on please okay
okay wonderful wonderful okay so that's
that's my presentation on behalf of the
public health group does anybody else
from the group one I had any comments